if hillary clinton becomes president of
the united states tonight god forbid
shall have one force to thank above all
others the love and protection of the
mainstream media yes they've covered her
foibles but only after being forced to
do so by WikiLeaks in the FBI sure
they've criticized her but only just
enough to maintain the patina of
credibility in reality the media pushed
Clinton to her perch atop the Democratic
Party then ensured that she would stay
there despite being destroyed by Barack
Obama in 2008 and nearly beaten by
septuagenarian asylum escapee Bernie
Sanders in 2016 a charisma free grading
personality visionless candidate like
Hillary never could have ascended to the
white house without her friends in the
media if nothing else this election has
exposed the media for what they are
between New Democratic National
Committee Chair donna Brazile funneling
CNN Town Hall questions to Hillary and
the network's running anti-trump
fact-checking Chiron's under Trump
speeches the media have made pretty
clear where they stand which is a good
thing next time around no matter how
this goes Republicans will have one
crucial advantage nobody nobody nobody
will trust the line media to tell the
truth about the next Republican hbo's
Bill Maher admitted he'd spent more than
a decade fibbing about Republicans in
their Hitlerian tendencies then of
course immediately called Donald Trump
Hitler he'll do the same thing in 2020
but Americans won't take him seriously
after all we've now seen the Democrats
and the media but I repeat myself will
treat Mitt Romney and Donald Trump
exactly the same way which means they'll
treat the 2020 nominee if Trump loses
the same way which means we should never
ever ever take their opinions seriously
on candidates ever again this election
has been a real acid test for everyone
from Democrats two Republicans but the
ultimate losers of this acid test are
the members of the press who may have
told the partial truth about Donald
Trump but in doing so demonstrated how
often they lie outright about non-trump
Republicans and in favor of all
Democrats I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
so today has come election day is here
and we have so much to talk about i'm
going to give you sort of my election
got maybe five arguments in favor of
voting for Donald Trump and five
arguments against voting for Donald
Trump today we'll try to be as fair
minded about that as possible will go
through all of the news of the day but
first we have to say hello to our
friends over at Birch gold so if you're
feeling uncertain if you're feeling
weary about the future if you're feeling
as though you're adrift in a sea of crap
well perhaps you should think about
investing in precious metals to protect
yourself from the vagaries and
vicissitudes of the United States
economy particularly in real estate and
the stock market Birch gold calm is the
place to go for that Birch gold calm /
Ben these are the precious metal IRA
specialists if you want with your IRA or
401k out of the stock market into
precious metals this is the place to go
they'll give you a 16-page freak it ask
all your questions they have an A+
rating from the better business bureau
it's virtual Birch gold calm / ben bir
CH gold calm / ben and and now is a good
time to call because i think that
there's some chaos a brewin so vertical
calm is the place to go make sure you
use the / pens they know we sent you and
they continue advertising with us and
therefore paying the the for the
employment of our of our unemployable
producers otherwise okay so today is the
day we have finally arrived you didn't
think that it would happen and let me
say everybody is very excited to vote
this live video from people rushing out
to the polls actually yep there it is
people very pumped up about voting today
and I'm very excited to announce that we
have a real choice on our hands pretty
spectacular choice between two of the
best candidates America has to offer
this is debate 2004 with your host Jim
lair welcome to the cable access
televised debate between a giant douche
and a turd sandwich we'll start with
giant douche sir some students and
parents are reluctant to have a giant
douche represent them what do you say to
those people Jim first of all I would
like to thank you for monitoring this
debate and I would like to thank all of
the students and their parents for
coming Oh shucks up stock up Shh wait
that's an obvious suck-up move but I
would hope that those students and their
parents who questioned my qualities
would simply look
my opponent he is a turd sandwich you're
a turd sandwich no sir if you'll pardon
me you are in fact the turds you're a
turd sandwich sir you are a turd Santa
guys pretty exciting and and in fact you
know look it is a binary vote it's a
two-party system one or the other of
these people are gonna win and it really
matters we've been told this is the most
important election of our lifetime it's
a it's a two-party system politics of
failure have failed we need to make them
work again tomorrow when you are sealed
in the voting cubicle vote for me
Senator Bob Dole I am looking forward to
an orderly election tomorrow which will
eliminate the need for a violent
bloodbath America take a good look at
your beloved candidates they're nothing
but hideous face reptiles
it's true we are aliens but what are you
going to do about it it's a two-party
system you have to vote for one of us
well I believe I'll vote for a third
party candidate go ahead throw your vote
away yes it's a very important election
it is it's very very important in this
election and and you know look the fact
is that we're lucky we live in a country
where voting is an everyday process
where it's where it's easy and it's free
and everyday processes never have bad
consequences at all as you see ya yeah
well there may be some bad consequences
yeah okay I could go badly and I know
everybody is very up today everybody's
very excited I know that people are
eager to go to the polls people are just
people are really really really excited
we're really feeling it today I mean we
have some live footage from some folks
you know just and and you know how
people are really feeling just about
this election cycle um yeah make sure
you enjoy a drink today you know just
feel good about yourself cuz it's
America yeah just you really got ya
that's how we're feeling today America
is soaring like an eagle today we are
just more flying like a nikka into the
future make sure that you dress up when
you go to the polls today as well I mean
you make sure we put on your put on your
Tuesday best as i like to say and i know
i'm pretty stoked for the election
results tonight yep just launched
yourself right into the stratosphere
that's how things are just going
spectacularly this is today you know
this how i sort of feel about this i got
to be honest now if you're really if
you're really revved up for the vote
today I don't blame you i mean it's an
exciting day really really is exciting
and if all else fails I mean if all else
fails then you can always just hang
under your favorite tree you can do that
as well so just you know I know
everybody's very pumped up and I know
we're all excited to go but but look the
outcome is already preordained there are
only going to be winners in this
election cycle we laugh so we don't cry
folks I mean this is just the way that
this has to be so it's a pretty pretty
spectacular canas I'd um it's crappy day
it's just a crappy day and so now we're
going to go through some of the
arguments for and against voting for
Donald Trump because here's the reality
as I've said before there are good
arguments for voting for Donald Trump to
stop Hillary Clinton there are good
arguments for not voting for Donald
Trump because he's a turd so the will go
through those arguments I'm going to try
not to bias these arguments you know
where I stand on this I'm not voting for
either of these two people because crap
sandwich versus giant douche neither of
them meet my basic standard for human
beings who get to be President of the
United States and my vote means
something to me beyond the instrument of
my vote but I want to go through the
honest arguments for voting for Donald
Trump because I think that there are a
lot of people who are convinced by these
arguments and I'm not going to try and
argue you out of it I'm just going to
make the arguments on both sides so I
think there are five good arguments for
voting for Donald Trump first of all
there are people who argue that if
you're voting for Trump you're not
voting for Trump the person you're
voting for Donald Trump's platform or
against Hillary Clinton's platform so
you don't have any moral qualms right my
vote for Trump is not a vote for Trump
it's vote for all these other things
that I think are not Trump Dennis Prager
says this my friend he says that voting
Trump is the most decent thing you can
do with your vote you're showing Hillary
that she can't get away with this sort
of corruption and left ism your vote is
just a vote it expires November 9th you
might as well use it against the person
you like the least your vote is an
instrument of policy only then there's
the most popular pro Trump argument
which is really just the Trump is better
than Hillary right the argument he saw
in that southpark cartoon the Trump is
better than Hillary Andrew Clavin my
good friend we were having a knock-down
drag-out battle before the show about
this particular argument but basically
what he says that there's a binary
election one of these two people is
going to be President and he right
today in principle and to some degree in
truth for a conservative not to choose
is to give aid to the greater leftist
Hillary Clinton these people are bad but
one of them is going to be President and
if one is better than the other it's my
patriotic duty to try to figure out
which one that is and vote for him or
her Trump is clearly better Dennis of
course agrees yes apiece over at
national review today and says the only
relevant moral lesson here is not that
the lesser of two evils is still evil it
is that choosing the lesser of two evils
by definition increases good and he says
that we know Hillary will be awful Trump
may not be and Victor Davis Hanson
basically says that he on a bunch of
issues like the Supreme Court and
Obamacare and the dead and rebuilding
the military in the Second Amendment
Trump is different than Hillary and
better than Hillary so that's the Trump
is better than Hillary argument which is
which has some merit to it third
argument in favor of voting for Donald
Trump today and this comes from EDD
Morrissey at hot air and Andrew makes
the same argument basically Trump is
less corrupt than Hillary Clinton he's
been part of this crony capitalist
machine but Hillary has actively
corrupted government that's that's what
ed morrissey rights at hot air drew says
there will be moments and grotesque bad
behavior that will lower the dignity of
the office from Trump but they'll be
nowhere near as damaging is a new
Clinton nakhra see she'll corrupt
government itself from segun but if you
were as dirty as Clinton we'd already
know about it so Clinton will corrupt
government in in a new way by exposing
the executive branch to her corruption
even more than what Obama has done
trumple do the same thing he may not
drain the swamp is he's fond of saying
but he'll be better than Hillary on that
the fourth argument that I've seen is
why worry about character why worry
about any of trumps foibles why worry
about the fact that the guy's terrible
the Democrats do this stuff all the time
why hand them the electoral advantage
why can't we be built the hand them why
would we hand them the electoral
advantage of they solidify behind their
candidate no matter who he or she is
while we have qualms we can't hand them
that sort of advantage Republicans have
to hold their note and vote in the same
way the Democrats hold their nose and
vote or we'll never win another election
and finally there's the argument that I
think underlies a lot of this and this
one comes courtesy of Dennis as well
also this is the flight 93 election
argument and Dennis says that he's not
willing to turn America over to four
more years of leftism since the damage
would be permanent he says America as
envisioned since its founding as the
beacon of individual liberty Lincoln's
last best hope of Earth it won't be here
this is the end stop this is the last
stop if it's the last stop you can
either go to trump town or you can go to
Hillary ville those are the only two
choices the last stop on the train is
this election cycle that's it we're done
ok and then flight 93 election basically
says the same thing we either hitting
the building or hitting the ground but
this is the last stop for the plane so
you may as well hit the ground as
opposed to letting this hit the World
Trade Centers now here are the arguments
and a lot of people find these arguments
convincing I'm not going to try to
convince you that those arguments are
wrong or false I think they're flawed I
do that's why I'm not voting but I find
some of these arguments have logic that
is compelling okay now I want to talk
about the five arguments against voting
for Trump for a concern from a
conservative perspective but no by the
way there are 0 arguments for voting for
Hillary there are no arguments promoting
for Hillary Hillary does not reflect any
character or policy positions the
conservatives should support in any way
and in fact it is imperative that
conservatives never show support for
Hillary Clinton because then it gives
her permission to do all the terrible
things that she's going to do so these
are just five arguments basically for
voting for mcmullen or for not voting at
the top of the ticket at all I voted
today already in California I did not
vote at the top of the ticket which is
something I did not foresee certainly
when this election cycle started and
makes me sick to my stomach as I sit
here okay so here are five arguments for
forgoing voting in favor of Donald Trump
first of all your vote is more and I
think this is true your vote is more
than an instrument of policy so the
Trump people say look your vote is a
coupon it expires November ninth and
that's it you use it you don't use it
doesn't really matter to anybody else
your votes are vote that's all I don't
think that's true particularly for
public figures when you vote you send a
message this is acceptable it's the
reason I would never vote for Hillary
Clinton you cannot vote against Hillary
without also voting for Donald Trump you
can't everybody inherently understands
this if you can simply vote from one or
the other as an instrument of policy a
lot of Republicans would vote for
somebody like David Duke to repeal
Obamacare in the Senate so ask yourself
this you have a minimum standard
everybody has a minimum standard of a
Republican who they think they agree
with more on policy but they wouldn't
vote for on character grounds does
Donald Trump meet your basic standard on
character grounds Trump may meet your
standard for president but if he doesn't
that's a problem even if you hate and
despise Hillary Clinton
and think she'll be terrible as I do
Donald Trump's policy knowledge is nil
he's an ad-hoc nationalist populists he
panders to some of the worst people on
the planet from Vladimir Putin to the
alt right he has no history of listening
to his advisors despite all talk to the
contrary he said he wants to cut the
olap Democrats he is toxic to every
demographic group that is growing in the
United States he's the worst Republican
candidate of my lifetime which is why
he's losing to the worst Democratic
candidate of my lifetime Hillary Clinton
if you earn your vote then you earned
your vote but if you didn't earn your
vote then maybe your vote has to be
earned maybe it's not just a coupon that
expires november nine that's argument
number one your vote is more than an
instrument of policy it says something
about your minimum standards for
qualifications for the Oval Office
argument number two okay the Trump that
people have been building up is fantasy
Trump Trump will not just be he won't be
a good president he'll be a mediocrity
at best so let's not make the argument
the Trump is going to be some sort of
Great God kingdom comes in and fixes
everything it's not true okay first of
all on Supreme Court justices which is
the one you hear all the time the
chances that Donald Trump nominates and
confirms a Supreme Court justice was
conservative are essentially nil this
entire election cycle was predicated on
the idea that senator Mitch McConnell
the Senate Majority Leader that senator
Mitch McConnell was going to ram through
what was a wimp I mean I was the inside
the entire election cycle was Mitch
McConnell's a giant pansy we need
somebody who's a tough guy that was the
entire election cycle right well now the
idea is Donald Trump's going to nominate
somebody Mitch McConnell will have maybe
50 senators maybe 50 senators and then
he's going to ram through a conservative
using the nuclear option it ain't going
to happen okay he's often on trade Trump
is he's awful on foreign policy he's a
Buchanan night isolationist paleo
conservative his pro-life stance is
dicey at best it's better than Hillary
Clinton's for sure but I don't think
he's going to be strong on abortion in
any real way he said he doesn't mind
losing the Senate cuz he wants to cut
deal with Democrats he will multiply the
debt he says he wants to expand
entitlements he says he wants to reveal
a repeal Obamacare but by the same token
he says he wants to expand Medicaid so
you don't have to create fantasy Trump
but people have been creating fantasy
Trump which means that the fourth
argument against voting Trump is
happening right now handing the
conservative movement over to trump is a
big mistake if you support Trump it
means you're handing party leadership
over to him it means carving the heart
out of a possible constitutional
conservative party and
lacing it with Steve Bannon esque
nationalist populism Trumpy and
nationalist populism which basically is
just big government leftism on behalf of
a voting bloc that Donald Trump likes
better Donald Trump has never talked
about freedom of liberty he doesn't care
about the Constitution he actually sees
these things as obstacles to his Trump
Ian rule and fixing all the problem
fixing unwritten uncuffing the system
for his supporters it turns the
republican party into a far-right
nationalist party from europe and that's
not something i want to see happen
fourth argument Republicans are better
than Democrats okay the argument before
from the other side was Republicans have
to act like Democrats if we want to win
the counter-argument is Republicans
should never act like Democrats because
Democrats act like bad people when it
comes to elections and we shouldn't just
fall into that trap morally and finally
this is the one I think is the most real
this is not the last election this is
not the last election okay Hillary will
be an awful president chances are she
will also be a week President she'll be
crippled by her own corruption she will
probably experience a recession while
she is president of the United States
she's going to have to fight a
Republican Congress and if not a
Republican Senate this year then a
Republican Senate in two years in 2018
Hillary lost to Obama in 2008 she nearly
lost to an old socialist loon bag in
2016 the chances are pretty good that
she loses in four years so if this isn't
the last election ever you have to make
a calculation do you think that Hillary
Clinton for four years is worse than
Republicans for the next eight after
that non-trump Republicans for the next
eight after that or do you think that
Donald Trump's mediocrity for four years
is better than eight years of democratic
dominance after becks let's face this
thing okay Donald Trump wins today he's
not going to be winning in four years
he's not going to be running against the
worst candidate Democrats have ever
fielded it's not going to happen they'll
run somebody young they'll run somebody
better they'll run somebody who's likely
to beat Donald Trump who is really
really unpopular Plus Donald Trump's
going to spend the next four years
making asinine comments about every
minority group that he can possibly find
and alienating all of them so those
those are the arguments against voting
for Trump's and now it's up to you
you're an adult I've given you all the
arguments for voting Trump that are good
and here's in and I've given you all the
arguments that are voting against Trump
and those are all the arguments now have
to take a while you consider your vote
we've take a brief break and say hello
to our advertisers over at lift so lift
is is the best car share service and the
best of the best
car sharing service there's a reason
that President Obama wants to become a
driver for the other car sheriff service
lift is is the best one I know this
because my wife takes lift when she has
to get off rotations late at night she's
a doctor she gets off rotations late at
night and she's too tired to drive
because sunsafe I trust my wife safety
with lifts and so does she and that
means that they really screen their
drivers in a pretty thorough going way
all their cars have to be I think within
the last five years you can tip in the
app which leads to happier drivers and
better drivers who are driving for lift
it isn't the biggest ride-sharing app
but it is the fastest growing in the
highest rated ride-sharing app lyft
offers our listeners a special deal if
you get the app and you enter promo code
Shapiro then you got thirty dollars off
you get a thirty dollar value its 23
free rides of ten dollars is what you
get if you use lift and use the promo
code Shapiro today and it is the best
ride-sharing app there is in the country
that's promo code Shapiro and again I
wouldn't trust them with my wife safety
unless I actually thought that they were
a service that is worth using that is
that is lift to download the app today
on your phone they really are terrific
okay so all of that said everybody is
now making their final pitches Barack
Obama is making his final pitch and
again every time you listen to Democrats
this is the way the dis election works
every time you listen to Democrats you
want to vote Republican and every time
you listen to Donald Trump you want to
shoot yourself in the face so Bruce Oh
Barack Obama makes his final pitch and
he makes a strong play why you should
vote for Donald Trump here he is saying
that we have to make the GOP pay for not
listening to me you know gridlock is not
mysterious it's not something that
happens because both sides are being
equally unreasonable it has been a
stated Republican strategy since I took
on us and the only way to break it is to
make those who engage in it pay a price
by electic more Democrats tomorrow okay
so he says that we have to elect
Democrats because that way people like
Obama can ram through their agenda
thankfully it looks like the Senate is
at least today the polls show that it's
pretty dead even Republicans will
maintain the house good shot that
Republicans may even keep the Senate 538
has it as a toss-up right now like
literally 50 50 i think it's 50 point
three percent chance democrats take the
Senate 49.7 percent chance Republicans
maintain the Senate at the very least
you have to vote today
and vote down ticket even if you choose
not to vote for Trump you have to vote
down ticket for your senator to stop
Hillary Clinton and stop the left's
agenda because the fact is that Obama is
just whatever you think of Mitch
McConnell in the Senators and I think
that a lot of them are terrible the fact
is that Obama's agenda in the first two
years does not even come close to what
he was not able to accomplish in the
last six all of his hard work Obamacare
the stimulus package all the most brutal
stuff that Obama did except for daca and
the executive orders the immigration
executive orders which he could have
done anyway because he did it as the
president and then he lost in court
about it all of that happened in the
first two years handing Hillary Clinton
a democratic senate is a dangerous
dangerous thing and we should make
Hillary Clinton pay at the very least by
giving her a Congress that she has to
overcome yeah we have to unfortunately
stop the live feed at facebook now but
if you want to subscribe watch the rest
of today's show go over to daily wire
calm right now eight bucks a month will
get you access it's gonna be a very very
busy week we'll be back by on facebook
tonight by the way and we are doing a
live broadcast on facebook of the
election coverage night me drew Andrew
Klavan Jeremy boring is the managing
editor who usually hides in his office
but will actually be part of the
broadcast tonight I hope you here too we
have a stellar lineup of guests Jonah
Goldberg is stopping by steven crowder
is stopping by it really is a big cast
tonight at glenn beck is stopping by
it's it's it's a bunch of people who are
stopping by both never Trump and proton
people are stopping by so it should be a
lot of fun but daily wire calm to
subscribe and right now if you get the
annual subscription you still get a free
copy of my book true allegiance signed
and you can be part of the team that
brings you the the most the most widely
listen to conservative podcast in
America
you